dire quoi que ce soit
voilà nous interrompt pour nos
programmes pour suivre en direct le
discours de nicolas sarkozy à l'issue
d'un conseil européen extraordinaire
consacré à la situation en libye nombre
de pays
d'afrique du nord
et du golfe
la conviction qui est la nôtre
c'est qu'il s'agit d'un mouvement
historique
qu'il convient de saluer
des peuples arabes
exigent à leur tour
la démocratie
le progrès social
et la croissance économique
ce mouvement historique
notre conviction
est qu'il ne s'arrêtera pas
qu il impactera
l'ensemble des pays
selon un rythme qui leur appartient de
décider
et que l'europe qui partage avec ces
pays une zone géographique la
méditerranée
se doit des doublements à l'auteur de
l'événement
d'abord parce que les valeurs qui sont
mises en avant aujourd'hui par les
peuples arabes sont des valeurs
que les nations européennes
ont fait leur il ya déjà bien longtemps
et deuxièmement
parce que nous sommes des voisins
géographiques
et nous sommes donc au premier rang
impacté est concerné par la réussite
de ces révolutions arabes
et c'est ce qui avait fait la france a
demandé la réunion de ce conseil
européen
indépendamment de ce contexte le conseil
européen s'est penché d'abord sur la
question libyenne
les décisions que nous avons prises sont
donc les suivantes le conseil européen
est unanime pour demander le départ du
colonel kadhafi
et de ses séides
le conseil précisant qu' en aucun cas le
colonel kadhafi ne peut être reconnu
comme un interlocuteur
du conseil européen
c'est un point majeur
qui fait l'unanimité
monsieur kadhafi n'est pas un
interlocuteur pour l'europe
le conseil européen
a décidé
je cite les mo de mémoire
de saluer
et d'encourager
le conseil national de transition
basé à benghazi
qu'il considère désormais comme un
interlocuteur politique
donc le premier temps du raisonnement
monsieur kadhafi n'est plus un
interlocuteur
il doit partir
deuxième temps du raisonnement le
conseil national de transition basé à
benghazi est pour le conseil européen de
l'interlocuteur politique son action est
saluée et encouragée alors
que deviendra le conseil est-ce qu'il
évoluera c'est aux libyens naturellement
d'en décider pas nous
mais il était très important notamment
pour la france
que soit reconnu le statut d'
interlocuteur politique
à ce conseil national de transition
pour éviter un risque
entre guillemets de somalisation c'est à
dire d'un pays dont on dirait
le dirigeant actuel n'est plus un
interlocuteur
mais il n'ya plus l'interlocuteur
donc l'interlocuteur politique c'est le
conseil national de transition c'est la
deuxième décision
troisième décision le conseil décide
que l'union européenne
permettra l'accès des agences et des
opérateurs humanitaires
à des zones humanitaires
dont nous n'avons pas précisé où elle
serait pour traiter la question des
déplacés dans un premier temps
certainement en tunisie et en egypte
mais nous souhaitons qu assez rapidement
ces zones humanitaires puissent exister
en libye qu'elle soit protégée
ont géré la question des dizaines de
milliers de personnes déplacées
et qu'il y ait dans ces zones
humanitaires
des moyens sanitaires des écoles de
façon à pouvoir accueillir ces
populations déplacées
le conseil européen par ailleurs
exprime
sa profonde inquiétude
au sujet des attaques y compris
aériennes contre des civils libyens non
violent
le conseil européen pour protéger la
population civile
ses états membres
examinera le conseil et les et le
conseil examinera les états membres
examineront
toutes les options nécessaires
pourvu qu'il y est un besoin démontrable
d'une action une claire base juridique
les nations unies et le soutien régional
je veux dire la ligue arabe
c'est dans le texte du conseil européen
le conseil européen a décidé sur
proposition de la france
de proposer l'organisation dans les
prochaines semaines très rapidement d'un
sommet tripartite ligue arabe union
africaine union européenne pour évoquer
l'ensemble de la situation
et notamment pour parler de la
refondation nécessaire de l'union pour
la méditerranée
le conseil européen a également décidé
la convocation sans délai d'un conseil
giles délire d'un conseil des ministres
de l'intérieur
pour
concerter la politique migratoire au
niveau de l'europe et renforcer les
moyens de frontex
les ministres intérieur européen devant
d'ailleurs prendre contact avec leurs
homologues de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée pour voir comment on peut
organiser la maîtrise des flux
migratoires
d'un côté et de l'autre de la
méditerranée
voilà mesdames et messieurs que j'en
terminerai en vous disant par ailleurs
le conseil européen a souhaité saluer
comme il se doit le très important
discours du roi du maroc
proposant une transformation
constitutionnelle de son pays pour faire
évoluer encore un peu plus loin
le maroc vers une monarchie
constitutionnelle est une démocratie le
conseil a tenu à saluer cette démarche
historique
spontanée volontaire
comme étant particulièrement exemplaire
voilà mesdames et messieurs je n'ai même
pas le texte en anglais
même pas le texte en français complet
puisque je vais devoir retourner pour
maintenant un deuxième sommet que la
france avait demandé
sommet de la zone euro pour parler de la
gouvernance économique de la zone euro
et je dois y retourner à 17h30
pesticides a bien sûr si vous aviez des
questions je me prêterait bien
volontiers
ce président est ce que les autres pays
du conseil européen ont décidé d'envoyer
une représentation diplomatique comme la
france auprès du conseil national de
transition
il faut que je sois très précis parce
que il ya eu des longs débats tout vous
comprenez bien que c'est la situation
est mouvante dans un certain nombre de
pays notamment libye il a fallu
harmoniser les positions de 27 personnes
tout le monde considère que monsieur
kadhafi n'est plus un interlocuteur tout
le monde considère qu'il ne peut plus
être quelqu'un avec qui on discute
et tout le monde considère que le
conseil
de l'opposition
le conseil national de transition un par
ailleurs est un interlocuteur politique
qui doit être saluée et encouragée
alors cela veut dire que ceux qui veut
le reconnaître comme tel ce que fait la
france ce qu'a fait le parlement
européen puisque j'ai entendu le
président du parlement européen qui a
d'ailleurs salué la france comme pays
leaders pour avoir reconnu l'opposition
libyenne d'autres pays considèrent qu on
doit discuter politiquement avec ce
conseil
que c'est parfaitement nécessaire mais
préfère attendre un petit peu que sa
composition soit stabilisée mais pour
tous l'expression c'est salué et
encouragé ce conseil et le considérer
comme un interlocuteur politique au nom
pour moi c'est très clair c'est un
interlocuteur politique c'est avec eux
qu'on discute et je crois que d'ailleurs
de ce point de vue la décision prise par
le parlement européen est sans ambiguïté
jeu quel est l'autre choix
monsieur le président quel accueil a
reçu la proposition franco-britannique
d'actions ciblées purement défensives en
libye en cas d'utilisation d'armes
chimiques ou d'utilisation d'armes
l'aviation du colonel kadhafi contre les
civils je tiens à rappeler que même si
c'est la partie que je comprends qu'ils
vous intéresse la proposition
franco-britannique à ma connaissance
comportait six points vous n'en parlez
coda
oui madame
bien sûr partir de chômage puisque la
proposition franco britannique consiste
à dire le conseil de transition c'est un
interlocuteur politique il faut des
zones humanitaires monsieur kadhafi doit
partir il doit y avoir un sommet
tripartite
c est l ensemble bon alors sur cette
question il n'ya pas en europe ceux qui
sont partisans d'une d'une option
militaire et ceux qui sont partisans une
option politique tout le monde est
partisan d'une option politique et
diplomatique j'avais eu l'occasion
moi-même au dépôt au départ de dire
toutes mes réserves sur une action de
l'otan
et de souligner toute la complexité
d'une no fly zone sur un territoire la
libye qui est grosso modo grand comme
trois fois la france et les moyens que
ça mettait en oeuvre
donc l'option militaire
massive comme l'a très bien dit
d'ailleurs le ministre d'état alain
juppé qui je tiens à rendre hommage
ensemble déplacement en egypte et puis
pour la la réunion qu'il a tenue hier
avec les ministres des affaires
étrangères
sur ce sujet donc la position de la
france n'a jamais été d'une option
militaire au sol
d'une option militaire de l'otan et a
toujours été réservé sur la no fly zone
même si nous n'avons pas décidé de
fermer cette option
mais la question qui se pose
un certain nombre de pays dont les
britanniques et nous
c'est qu'est-ce qui se passe
si des populations pacifiques civile
en train de manifester sans violence et
pacifiques en
sont la cible
des quelques avions de monsieur kadhafi
en l'occurrence l'aimer
ou de quelques hélicoptères
qui tirent sur la foule
et la question que nous avons posée avec
monsieur cameron c'est à ce moment là
doit-on regarder des images
ou doit-on réagir
et c'est la raison pour laquelle
monsieur juppé moi même nous avons parlé
d'opérations possibles
strictement défensive
ciblées sur quelques objectifs
militaires
au cas où
des populations civiles sans défense
se voyait massacrés par une action
militaire
massive sur eux
alors nous avons posé un certain nombre
de conditions
un mandat des nations unies
du conseil de sécurité
le soutien des partenaires nous visons
naturellement la ligue arabe est par
ailleurs les autorités libyennes que
nous reconnaissons comme des
interlocuteurs politiques
et bien sûr des agressions massives
par des moyens militaires
sur des populations désarmées et non
violentes et civils
c'est dans ce cadre là que se pose la
question
et nous sommes très satisfaits monsieur
cameron et moi que le texte du conseil
européen exprime sa profonde inquiétude
au sujet des attaques aériennes
et indique pour protéger la population
civile les états membres examineront je
cite toutes les options nécessaires
et vous comprenez bien que toutes les
options nécessaires examiné par les
états européens dans ce cas ne sont pas
que des options diplomatiques en posant
des verrous un besoin démontrable
ce que je vous indiquais des avions de
chasse militaire qui frapperait une une
foule de manifestants sans défense
une claire base juridique
une décision des nations unies et le
soutien régional
le soutien régional ce sont les
autorités politiques que nous
considérons en libye et la ligue arabe
alors
cessez personne ne le souhaite
mais il est clair que l'europe envoie un
signal et n'a pas voulu exclure cette
option je crois en vous disant ça j'ai
résumé
l'état d'esprit
du conseil aux personnes nées favorable
à une option militaire
elle personne de l'envisagent de façon
massive terrestre
et lors de mon entretien avec les
autorités du conseil national de
transition libyen mais
nos interlocuteurs politiques désormais
eux-mêmes mendient combien
serait maladroit
une intervention étrangère que nous
n'envisageons nullement mais il ya un
mais c'est le cas de figure précis où
des attaques systématiques seraient
engagées contre des populations civiles
qui serait massacrés par des moyens
militaires
dans david carretta de radio radical une
radio italienne est ce que il ya le
temps de poursuivre
les voies internationales dont les
nations unies la ligue arabe l'union
africaine ou est-ce que à votre avis un
certain moment il faudrait apprendre
aussi une décision européenne ou d'un
certain groupe de pays européens
bon là la délibération est clair il faut
une claire base juridique
pour intervenir un mandat des nations
unies c'est nécessaire c'est préférable
nous le souhaitons dans
sia pas ce mandat et qui a une demande
régionale et libyenne nous verrons à ce
moment là mais vous comprenez quand même
que la réunion du conseil européen
elle était très attendu en libye
elle est très regardé par les époques
les différents peuples arabes
si nous avions décidé d'exclure toute
autre option aujourd'hui qu'elle signale
aurions nous envoyer ça veut pas dire
qu'on veut ça veut pas dire qu'on
souhaite
enfin l'europe c'est le grand voisin
nous avons la méditerranée en partage
les peuples arabes ont décidé de se
battre pour leur liberté et pour la
démocratie
notre devoir c'est de répondre à cette
aspiration
alors bien sûr le processus n'est pas
aboutie notre conviction à nous français
c'est que ce processus impactera petit à
petit l'ensemble d'une manière ou d'une
autre l'ensemble des états de la région
qu'on est qu'au début d'un processus
dont nul ne sait dans quel sens ça va
pas ça va aller et comment ça pas
terminée néanmoins le conseil européen
avec ses décisions et en proposant la
demande de la france un sommet
tripartite
se comporte en partenaire régional de
premier plan enfin souvenons nous dans
d'autres crises je pense à la bosnie ou
d'autres sujets
vous même et vos confrères à l'époque
avait pointé du doigt l'absence de
réaction de l'europe son absence totale
alors que enfin plutôt son suivisme dans
certains cas alors même qu'il s'agissait
de notre région mais je ne peux pas vous
dire comment ça va se terminer ou
comment ça ça valait mais la décision du
conseil européen
me semble être une décision
très forte ça veut pas dire qu'à pas des
différences de sensibilité naturellement
président pardon une précision le mandat
de l'onu est il nécessaire où est-il
seulement préférable ça c'est le premier
point
deuxième point dans la mesure où toutes
les conditions vous avez évoquées sont
réunies est ce que la france et la
grande bretagne seraient disposés à
engager leurs seules forces militaires
dans ses actions très précise ou bien
demanda-t-elle le concours d'autres
forces comme ça deux états unis par
exemple je ne souhaite pas aller plus
loin là dessus il ya trois conditions
des faits incontestables
une résolution des nations unies le
soutien régional
nous verrons c'est un cadre qui a été
fixée je crois que ce cadre et est
satisfaisant qu'il envoie un message à
tous ceux qui doivent le recevoir
et permet de dire que l'europe assume et
prend ses responsabilités qu'aurait-on
dit si l'europe décidé avant même d'y
réfléchir
de renoncer à toutes les options voilà
rien cadre qui fixait matin il faut
faire vivre ce cadre dira bien d'autres
événements les choses vont très vite
comme vous le savez vous l'avez vu en
tunisie vous l'avez vu en egypte
constate aujourd'hui en libye c'est ce
cadre et je veux m'en tenir à ce cadre
mais bon
chacun me semble-t-il a fait un pas l'un
vers l'autre et aînés s'il y avait eu
des malentendus ils ont pu être être
levé mais même sur le jeu comprend
d'ailleurs la sensibilité d'un certain
nombre de nos partenaires européens des
pays d'europe de l'est
eux mêmes en souvenir des processus de
transition d'ancien ministre
associé aux pouvoirs précédents ont joué
un rôle au début de la transition qui
n'était pas le rôle à la fin de la
transition
et eux mêmes ce que je peux parfaitement
comprendre quand il s'agit de discuter
avec tel ou tel kate ministre de
monsieur kadhafi se disent est ce que
c'est un interlocuteur snepap sur deux
ce n'est pas absurde de raisonner comme
cela mais nous leur avons fait valoir
que ces gens qui ont travaillé avec
monsieur kadhafi aujourd'hui risquent
leur vie
avril risquent leur vie
c'est pas rien
et ils ont engagé un processus
démocratique
est ce que ces gens là seront à la fin
du processus démocratique de libyens je
n'en sais rien dire c'est pas moi d'en
décider je ne suis pas libyens
mais risquent leur vie ces gens sont
sincères
et quel autre choix avons nous pour
discuter avec qui donc vous voyez c'est
patent des problèmes politiques c'est
aussi des problèmes de sensibilité
bon enfin si vous prenez d'autres
révolutions comme révolution des
oeillets au portugal avant d'être la
démocratie que nous connaissons il ya eu
des étapes enfin pour ceux qui se sont
intéressés à cette révolution au
portugal ça n'a pas été tout de suite
des démocrates absolue eu des gens qui
ont été dans les premières équipes qui
avaient collaboré avec la dictature de
monsieur saint lazare et je pourrais
prendre d'autres exemples vous regardez
en tunisie le premier ministre actuel a
été un proche de monsieur bourguiba
enfin comment faire autrement
je voudrais pas citer des pays oui voyez
la pologne va tous vous pouvez prendre
et il n'y a pas un pays me semble-t-il
non mais je ne surtout pas fait il n'y a
pas un pays me semble-t-il qui est passé
d'une situation de dictature une
situation de démocratie parfaite avec
des gens qui dans le cadre de la
démocratie tout d'un coup sont sortis de
nulle part alors qu'il n'avait exercé
aucune responsabilité avant je sais pas
si je me fais comprendre mais c'est ça
serait parfaitement impossible de dire
ah bon vous avez travaillé avec monsieur
kadhafi donc on peut pas travailler avec
vous s'ils prennent la responsabilité
ils risquent leur vie de créer un
mouvement démocratique en libye bien sûr
qu'ils ont travaillé dans le cadre d'un
système comment pouvait-il faire
autrement par ailleurs est ce qu'ils
seront à l'arrivée du processus
démocratique dans quelques mois dans
quelques années nous nul ne sait mais il
est refusé par principe alors même
lorsqu'il fait que nous on les
considérait donc comme des
interlocuteurs politiques
et non crédible mais eux en libye serait
vécu comme des opposants suffisamment
crédible pour risquer leurs vies
dites moi quelle situation voilà le
choix que que nous avons fait et voilà
la raison pour laquelle la france n'a
pas le parlement des russie a décidé de
de reconnaître ces gens j'ajoute qu'il
faut les encourager qu'est-ce qu'on veut
les pousser à la division qui est dans
chaque ville un nouveau conseil
favoriserait qui à ce moment là je crois
que c'est sage de faire comme cela
je joue tu que j'ai trouvé des gens
c'est raisonnable en tout cas ceux avec
qui j'ai discuté le président du
parlement européen ne faisait là la même
remarque je sais que le président
vandromme pas il va les rencontrer et
que madame catherine ashton les a
rencontrés aussi
les présidents sébastien maillard la
croix vous évoquez des transitions
démocratiques en cours dans la région et
notamment en tunisie en égypte en lieux
de la situation est loin d'être stable
est-ce que dada ce propos de la réponse
d'europe vous semble à la hauteur soit
base des discussions que vous avez pu
avoir aujourd'hui ce document de la
commission européenne et du service
d'action extérieure
au jeu concours vous répondre
franchement je pense qu'on est qu'au
début d'un processus
qui va nous engager aller beaucoup plus
loin incontestablement mais qui nous
amène à attendre aussi
enfin à respecter ces révolutions arabes
c'est à eux de conduire ces révolutions
et amener leurs processus c'est pas à
nous de définir ce dont ils ont besoin
lorsqu'ils sûr c'est que nous aurons
l'occasion de refonder l'union pour la
méditerranée qui est plus nécessaire que
jamais
il faut pour cela que nous ayons phase d
interlocuteur avec qui nous puissions
construire
cette relation
j'ai voulu ne pas me précipiter
s'agissant d'un grand pays amis comme la
tunisie et s'agissant d'un autre très
grand pays ami comme l'égypte pourquoi à
ceux qui m'appelait à me précipiter dans
la conférence de
reconstruction de la tunisie
qui avait été annoncé par le premier
ministre un outil
qui a dû démissionner à la suite d'un
vaste mouvement de foule qu'en étant dit
quant à l'egypte le ministre d'état
alain juppé a fait un voyage très réussi
là-bas
le premier ministre david cameron il y
avait été avant il y avait rencontré un
premier ministre égyptien qui a changé
deux jours après
donc certainement devra aller plus loin
réinventer un certain nombre de
mécanismes
pour les aider mais attendons que même
stabilise un peu lors leur leur système
démocratique
je pense que c'est une très bonne
nouvelle également que sur les la
gestion des flux migratoires nous
décidions des zones humanitaires en
afrique du nord pour gérer les
populations déplacées
que nous ayons décidé la réunion sans
délais des conseils des ministres
européens de l'intérieur
pour poser une politique européenne de
l'immigration
la décision de rencontrer les ministres
de l'intérieur d' afrique du nord pour
gérer ceci ensemble car il va de soi que
y compris sur les politiques migratoires
il faudra tenir compte du fait que ces
pays devenant des démocraties
le statut de réfugié politique depuis la
même nature je prends un exemple et
nous nous est qu'avant accueillis sur
notre territoire
une grande partie des opposants
politiques de monsieur ben ali
parce qu'ils avaient un statut de
réfugié politique aujourd'hui la tunisie
est une démocratie
les choses ne se pose pas de la même
manière mais pour les étudiants va bien
falloir qu'on les aide à former la
jeunesse
c'est donc tout l'ensemble qui dans les
mois qui viennent est ramenée être
repensée sans doute réorganisé
par dans le parmentier journal le monde
le président petite question vous avez
parlé d' armes chimiques ce matin est ce
que vous avez des éléments qui attestent
d'un usage probables ou possibles d'art
de chimiques par le bar monsieur kadhafi
deuxième question quand je vois ce qui
se passe et moi il faut des faits
tangibles pour vous permettre
éventuellement intervenir donc est ce
qui fait qu on puisse intervenir avant
que l'irréparable aucun crime
particulièrement gênant sur des civils
soit commis les troisième solution si
monsieur kadhafi on gagne sur le terrain
comment on s'en sort est ce la peine
situation j'allais dire à l'irakienne à
l'ancienne je vous ai fait un lapsus
amusant qui qui en dit long sur votre
tempérament vais parler de troisième
solution
parfois il m'arrive de penser que vous
voudriez bien cette place
et que vous le verriez bien la vôtre
j'ai compris c'est des questions vous me
posiez donc parfait un
bon show sur le l'opportunité de frappes
défensives et ciblées je me suis exprimé
en des tâches je peux pas vous en dire
plus
sur eux les cas chimiques je n'ai pas de
ta formation
précise
mais chacun sait que monsieur kadhafi
d'ailleurs c'était à porter à son crédit
et l'époque
à s'est séparé de son stock d'armes
nucléaires enfin dame tout cas de
réserve et de processus à l'époque et
c'était d'ailleurs à porter à son crédit
je l'avais souligné moi même
le fait qu'il puisse y avoir ou pas des
armes chimiques n'ai pas d'information
précise
mais enfin disons que
certains des acteurs se pose la question
et on me dit mais qu'est ce qui se passe
il monsieur kadhafi l'emportent mal
justement c'est in c'est une solution
que nous l'envisageons n'envisageons pas
politiquement puisque pour nous n'est
plus un interlocuteur
est justement tout ce que nous faisons
c'est cette nature à encourager
tous ces libyens qui veulent une
démocratie
et et qui doivent pouvoir s'appuyer sur
un soutien politique et économique
sans faille de l'europe
on peut pas considérer que
le fait que monsieur kadhafi
reste en place soit sur autre chose qu
une très mauvaise nouvelle pour
l'ensemble des pays de la région quel
signal mais je voulais dit de la même
façon sans comparer les situations en
côte d'ivoire
depuis le début la france se bat pour
que soit reconnu l'élection validée par
les nations unies du président ouattara
parce que c'est pas que la côte d'ivoire
dont il s'agit c'est l'ensemble de
l'afrique pourquoi faire des élections
si lorsque l'on fait des élections le
président élu ce n'est pas le président
en place et là il ya une révolution qui
mise en place des gens courageusement
qui disent nous si on veut la démocratie
on doit tout faire pour les aider ça
serait une catastrophe si ce n'était pas
le cas
peut-être une dernière question
oui merci beaucoup béatrice hajjaj
airtel je voulais savoir comme vous nous
expliquer que s'il ya un massacre vous
aimeriez que l'europe puisse anticiper
dès maintenant ce qu'elle est prête à
faire vous vous privilégiez des actions
ciblées vous nous l'avez dit alors est
ce que c'est une nouvelle vraiment que
ça que vous pensez qu axa qui est
important non non je ne le pense pas
mais à des questions c'est normal et moi
je me demandais c'était une nouvelle
doctrine diplomatique de la france c'est
à dire si en jordanie au yémen au koweit
toutes les manifestations contre les
pouvoirs en place tourne mal s'il ya des
répressions est ce que la france est
amenée comme ça proposez moi excusez moi
le président moubarak est parti a été
renversé à la suite de manifestations de
masse je n'ai jamais vu l'aviation
égyptienne
frapper les manifestants
il y a eu des brutalités il y a eu des
affrontements mais on est resté dans le
cadre de violences que je qualifierais
pardonnez l'expression de civils un vin
c'est sans doute pas la bonne expression
je m'en excuse auprès de vous mais je
veux dire que c'était brutal il ya eu de
la brutalité il ya eu des violences il
ya eu des manifestantes blessés sans
doute y ait eu des morts la fin ça n'a
rien à voir avec des moyens mais mille r
aérien qu'on envoie contre des gens qui
manifestent en tunisie il ya eu des
manifestants il ya eu des brutalités des
morts mais le président ben ali est
parti justement d'ailleurs en egypte
comme en tunisie
parce que l'armée a refusé de faire feu
sur la foule enfin seul dans son immense
majorité c'est quand même bien ça qui
s'est passé en tunisie comme en egypte
il y aurait pu avoir cette tentation
mais l'armée a dit non nous nous tirons
pas sur la foule
mais ce que c'est ce qui s'est passé en
libye
c'est que c'est quand même on peut pas
on peut pas dire que tout se ressemble
on peut pas dire que tout se vaut on
peut pas dire que toutes les situations
sont sans égal c'est pas parce que c'est
l'afrique du nord c'est pas parce que ce
sont des des populations arabes qui
veulent se libérer d'une forme de
dictature mais c'est pas du tout la même
la même je veux dire quelles conditions
de la répression de la brutalité ne sont
pas du tout les même si en libye nous
nous trouvions pas vécu le chef de
l'armée libyenne où des dirigeants de
l'armée des militaires
nous ne tirons pas sur la foule on est
dans et deux cas de figure jamais
personne n'a envisagé de faire des
actions militaires ciblées défense eve
en tunisie ou en égypte ça ne s'est même
pas posée non donc c'est pas du tout
inchangé excusez moi mais je me suis en
outre mal exprimé mais c'est pas du tout
un changement diplomatique que nous
envisageons c'est une adaptation une
situation tout à fait particulière qu'on
a absolument pas connu nulle part
peut-être le seul endroit où on a connu
une mobilisation d'un état state en iran
dans les conditions qu'on connaît encore
une fois et je n'ai pas vu à ce moment
là l'armée enfin l'aviation lancé pour
ce qu'on en sait donc il n'y a aucun
changement diplomatique une nouvelle
doctrine je suis opposée à une
intervention militaire d'ensemble j'ai
été je crois l'un des premiers à dire ma
réserve sur une intervention de l'otan
qui est une organisation militaire mais
entre eux refusé une intervention
militaire
et laisser des gens massacrés par des
avions de chasse alors qu'ils
manifestent il il ya peut-être à
réfléchir
sur ce qu'on fait si les nations unies
sont d'accord si la ligue arabe était
d'accord si un mandat et si ces faits
sont avérés on peut pas me faire part
dans mes mais je change ment
diplomatique ne pouvez pas comparer ce
qui se passe en libye aujourd'hui ce qui
s'est passé en tunisie
vous pouvez le comparer politiquement si
vous voulez vous ne pouvez pas comparer
la répression n'a rien à voir il ya par
exemple il ya des actes de guerre en
libye je ne pense pas que des actes de
guerre en egypte où des actes de guerre
en en tunisie il ya eu une révolution
politique avec des violences
naturellement mais là on est on est dans
des des villes bombardées des terminaux
pétroliers bombardé enfin ça ne ça n'a
rien à voir
dernière question
de jouer portable
est ce qu est ce qu'on peut monsieur
président puisque ça va se terminer très
tard est-ce qu'on peut anticiper juste
sur la réunion qui va suivre maintenant
une question sur la réunion qui va
suivre maintenant
parce que ça va devenir très tard après
donc je suis désolé pour votre nuit de
sommeil il n'y a pas de raison que vous
dormiez plus que moi dans ce cas là à
écouter nomme
jeu surtout pas désagréable avec vous
mais
je veux pas mélanger des choses parce
que
moi j'ai bien réfléchir la situation qui
nous occupe en afrique du nord c'est
historique alors je sais bien qu'on
emploie le mot historique à tout bout de
champ et ça méritait qu'on fasse un
conseil européen spécifique sur le sujet
c'était pas évident
non de mes partenaires ne le pensez pas
penser qu'une réunion des ministres des
affaires étrangères suffisait j'ai dit
ce que je pensais de l'action de d'alain
juppé qui nous travaillons bien sûr main
dans la main
mais je ne veux pas mélanger
l'importance des dix ans qu'on va
prendre tout à l'heure
les 17 membres de la zone euro est ce
qu'on vient de décider la ce et
s'écouter tant de fois dans le passé
j'ai regretté que l'europe n'exprime pas
une voie politique un chemin politique
claire
cas pas du moment où elle accepte de le
faire avec les citations les ambiguïtés
de que je reconnais bien voter la
situation n'est pas simple 1
c'est quand même une bonne nouvelle
c'est l'europe qui est en première ligne
et c'est l'europe qui doit assumer ce
choix politique bien sûr il faut en
parler avec nos amis nos alliés
américains naturellement mais nous
sommes les premiers comptes concernés
c'est quand même extraordinaire mon
important oui je vais m'en parler de
cette question là parce que c'est le
sujet on en a parlé pendant six heures
je veux pas parler d'autre chose même si
le gouvernement économique le pacte de
convergence et notre compétitivité c'est
absolument très important mais ce soir
alors
d'abord s'est mis d'accord sur le
principe de zones humanitaires parce que
je le dis à nos compatriotes
si on veut que ces révolutions arabes ne
provoquent pas de peurs
il faut que
avec franchise nous parlions de la
question des flux migratoires
il y à des populations déplacées peut
considérer qu'il y à quoi deux cent
mille personnes
200 milles je ne parle pas immigré deux
cent mille personnes déplacées entre la
lybie canton l'egypte la libye la
tunisie
si on ne traite pas l'accueil de ces
personnes déplacées dans des conditions
humaines et décentes
quelle va être la tentation de ces
personnes déplacées tentation n'ont pas
le choix c'est à verser la méditerranée
on nous ne pouvons pas les accueillir
dans ces conditions là
donc il faut organiser des zones
humanitaires dans notre esprit
ces zones devraient être gérées par les
nations unies alors est ce que c'est le
hcr l'office des migrations je ne sais
mais par les nations unies
l'europe
devrait bien sûr participer à son
financement à son organisation ce qui
est la seule façon de gérer
tranquillement la question des flux
migratoires
puis les conseils les ministres de
l'intérieur européens et d'afrique du
nord vont se réunir
pour voir ce dont ils ont besoin mais
naturellement la politique migratoire
doit évoluer
et doit être maîtrisée des deux côtés
nous devons continuer à accueillir
leurs étudiants
les hommes d'affaires
et ils doivent accepter de donner des
laissez passer consulaires pour les
immigrés en situation irrégulière qui
n'ont pas de papiers qui ont vocation à
retourner
dans leur pays donc on va essayer de
gérer ensemble profitons de cette crise
pour poser les bases non seulement d'une
politique d'immigration européenne mais
d'une politique d'immigration concernés
entre pays départ et pays d'arrivée
voilà et donc les nations unies me
semblerait la meilleure façon et avec ça
on peut gérer ces flux migratoires
sinon on n'aura quoi la multiplication
de l'onp et l'odeur
des personne ne peut le souhaiter
personnes
dont il faut organiser des zones
humanitaires
décentes
avec des écoles pour les enfants avec
des moyens sanitaires de manière à
maîtriser cela et pour moi les nations
unies c'est mieux ça même alors sa peau
il y aura d'autres questions qui
protègent ces zones humanitaires
j'imagine que vous avez ça
la france peut avoir des propositions à
faire et en fera sans doute mais dans le
cadre de ce conseil européen je préfère
qu'on s'en tienne
aux principes et après
step by step et tapas étape on
construira ce projet peut pas tout
résoudre
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup à tout à
l'heure donc
voilà pour cette conférence de presse de
nicolas sarkozy que vous avez pu suivre
en direct sur public sénat une
conférence de presse qui a eu lieu à
l'issue d'un conseil européen
extraordinaire
consacrée à la libye et pour commenter
cette conférence de presse michael
szames esma rejoint bon sens michael
nous allons revenir avec vous sur les
points clés de ce conseil européen et
pour commencer que peut-on retenir des
annonces de nicolas sarkozy
la principale en tout cas c'est que le
colonel kadhafi aujourd'hui n'est plus
un interlocuteur pour l'union européenne
et peut-être aussi pour les nations
unies mais en ce qui concerne le conseil
européen qui viennent se tenir à
l'instant le colonel kadhafi n'est plus
un interlocuteur aujourd'hui
l'interlocuteur privilégié pour la libye
c'est le conseil national de transition
que nicolas sarkozy a reçu hier à paris
et qui sera désormais le seul
interlocuteur possible pour l'union
européenne et pour les autres acteurs
mondiaux c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
l'union européenne demande tout
simplement au colonel kadhafi de se
retirer de ce de démissionner pour
laisser place à ce fameux conseil
national de transition c'est une chose
très importante car jusque là le colonel
kadhafi était encore possiblement un
interlocuteur aujourd'hui l'union
européenne le précise très fermement il
doit démissionner alors autre point
important de cette conférence de presse
nicolas sarkozy avait proposé ce matin
la création de zones humanitaires en
afrique du nord qu'en est il et c'est
très important c'est un plan très
important pour l'union européenne car on
parle de la 2d flux migratoires il y a
pratiquement 200 mille personnes ce qui
concerne la tunisie l'égypte et
aujourd'hui la libye 200 mille personnes
qui pourrait émigrer vers l'union
européenne et nicolas sarkozy l'a répété
il y à quelques instants il ne veut pas
de la multiplication de lampedusa l'on
paie tout ça est une petite île près de
l'italie où on accueille quasiment toute
la misère du monde ou en tout cas tous
ceux qui n'ont plus de papier qui
aujourd'hui veulent rentrer sur le
territoire européen
il décide de partir sur cette petite île
et donc c'est un énorme problème pour
l'union européenne qui est donc décidé
aujourd'hui de la création d'une zone
humanitaire même si cela donc encore
prendre un petit peu de temps une zones
humanitaires décentes at il dit sous la
décision des nations unies avec possible
le hcr qui pourrait être l'un des
responsables de ces zones humanitaires
évidemment rien est encore en place
parce que nous concerne le conseil
européen vient de se terminer les
décisions vont prendre du temps il y à
un conseil des ministres des affaires
européen des affaires étrangères
européens qui doit avoir lieu lundi
mardi à paris il y a également une
organisation tripartite entre l'union
africaine l'union méditerranéenne et
l'union européenne qui doit avoir lieu
dans les semaines à venir tout ça va
prendre beaucoup de temps ce qu'on peut
dire aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y aura une
politique migratoire sur les flux
d'immigration qui va se mettre en place
avec les différents acteurs au niveau
européen et c'est très important car
aujourd'hui en france et partout
ailleurs en europe il ya une vraie peur
celle d'une immigration massive de ces
pays dooky rue connu une révolution et
nicolas sarkozy l'a répété c'est un
mouvement historique qui se répétera et
qui touchera tous les autres pays du
secteur du bassin méditerranéen donc là
on touche à un problème central de la
politique intérieure mais de la
politique surtout européennes les flux
migratoires ce sera quelque chose de
très important autre point clé aussi à
préciser celle des frappes aériennes
nicolas sarkozy et david cameron la
grande pour la grande bretagne avait
demandé des frappes ciblées en cas
d'utilisation
d'armes chimiques par exemple de la part
du commandant qu'à la fille du colonel
kadhafi sur les civils ils n'ont pas eu
gain de cause apparemment il faudra
également demandé évidemment la vie tout
d'abord au conseil national de
transition il faudra également demandé
l'avis de la ligue arabe c'est très
important pour l'instant pas de frappes
aériennes en tout cas pas d'action
militaire et angela merkel l'a précisé
elle ne veut pas de frappes aériennes à
ce stade alors en gala merkel justement
puisque ce conseil européen pris
beaucoup de retard un retard
certainement huot divergences de points
de vues entre la france et la
grande-bretagne d'un côté et l'allemagne
de l'autre 6h conseil européen qui a
duré six heures c'est assez rare et
c'est vrai que le problème libyen en
vaut peut-être aussi
la chandelle si on peut dire c'est qu'il
fallait absolument régler ce problème en
interne entre les chefs d'état c'est
vrai que depuis hier il y avait une
position entre la grande bretagne et la
france qui voulait ses frappes aériennes
ciblées ou en tout cas qui voulait une
action militaire l'allemagne était
totalement opposée alors que d'habitude
lors de ses conseils européens il ya un
axe franco allemand très clair qui se
dessine aujourd'hui cet axe franco
allemand s'est on va dire pousser vers
un axe franco britannique angela merkel
elle a tenu une conférence de presse il
ya quelques instants pour dire très
clairement qu'elle ne voulait pas de
frappes aériennes on sent qu'il n'y a
pas encore de consensus
valable autres tous les pays européens
car le texte nicolas sarkozy l'a précisé
n'est pas encore clairement écrit il va
falloir encore sûrement travailler avec
les autres pays européens et notamment
le qu'angela merkel qui elle-même pour
l'instant est sur une position un peu
différente de celle des français et des
britanniques alors michael pour terminer
ce sommet européen a eu lieu à
l'initiative de nicolas sarkozy à suivre
un sommet extraordinaire de la zone euro
toujours à l'initiative de nicolas
sarkozy en tant que président du g20 ces
sommets est ce un moyen pour nicolas
sarkozy de redorer son blason n'oublions
pas qu'il est président du g20 est donc
à ce titre évidemment c'est normal qu'il
soit en pointe sur les questions
internationales mais c'est vrai que les
sondages en ce moment en france ne sont
pas très bons pour nicolas sarkozy alors
une façon de redorer son blason ou en
tout cas de se porter à l'offensive
c'est peut-être c'est peut-être vrai
c'est vrai qu'il a répété que la france
était à l'offensive et était la première
à demander cette réunion qu'on vient de
voir ce conseil extraordinaire européen
également cet après-midi en fin de
journée avec une conférence de presse
qui aura lieu très tard ce soir sur les
questions de l'euro c'est que ce sont
des problèmes qui concernent énormément
les français mais on sent bien qu'il ya
une stratégie de la part de nicolas
sarkozy d'être au dessus des problèmes
peut-être franco-français et de
s'intéresser aux problèmes du monde
comme étant le président du monde et
c'est peut-être là il faut y voir
peut-être aussi une stratégie politique
mais c'est vrai que la libye est un
grand problème mondial donc on peut lui
faire crédit en tout cas sur ce point de
s'intéresser d'être très actif sur la
question libyenne merci beaucoup mais
qu'elle nous reviendrons bien sûr sur ce
conseil européen extraordinaire dans
notre édition de 19 heures présentée ce
soir par pierre henri gergonne est très
bonne soirée sur public sénat
ce